got what we need - first love it that we
got ourselves a deal now why you want to
go and do that
but I don't see no muscle move
your partner is marrying your sister
good cop sex cop courney is the best
wedding planner in Atlanta so what
you're going to do not intimidated by
you
what you gonna do what speed was a fan
of all the new dealers in Atlanta are
getting supplied through Antonio Pope in
Miami you need to get me something on
this guy two days tops so get a team
together and fix this
Miami James I'm going make sure you're
back in time to make me mrs. black
hammer
top right drawer oh they were in my
panty drawer not yours we're gonna go
buy Miami PD let them know we're here
Oh soft tissue manipulation detective
Payton sexy first my shaking hand after
this Pope is mother contraband through
the port you're gonna help me get some
hard evidence on him how do we get an
undetected
no Prince Adam else even Mattoon Bay
plus my two servants
I'm not just serving what I say you are
find a respect I cannot see on my face
oh we got company
are you sick
the brothers-in-law just got to town you
say that again gonna shoot you in the
face
I need you here now I'm marrying someone
my nerves is bad
oh my god here zombie headshot walking
dead oh thank you
I fished up because my fancy a spinach
ever after you know I'm Dylan Atlanta